for the first time since March the
second the residents of Carson woke up
to sites and Sands of a city restored to
life
this is full body Square in the center
the world means freedom and with it
comes joy and laughter
it's time as such
but for as long as possible they'll
pretend it is
[Music]
the Russian army has merely retreated to
the east side of the danipro river
easily in artillery range as they
withdrew the Russians destroyed critical
infrastructure the TV tower bridges of
the denipro including this one near the
kakova dam causing significant damage of
parts of the dam wall
and satellite imagery shows a damaged
antonovsky Bridge the main Crossing from
west to east Russia announced that it
had completed an orderly withdrawal on
Friday morning but the evidence suggests
it was anything but
some units were forced to flee across
the temporary pontoons under heavy
Ukrainian fire
there were reports of drownings another
unit is said to have been ordered to
dress in civilian clothes and Escape by
any means available many Russian dead
and wounded are said to have been left
behind us
as of this evening the Defense Forces
have established control over more than
60 settlements in Quezon region the
police have started stabilization
measures everywhere in liberated
territory our expert technicians have
lots of work to do
almost 2 000 explosive items have
already been removed
for Russia it was the latest in a series
of Battlefield defeats and all the more
humiliating coming just six weeks after
her son was formally annexed by Moscow
for now Ukraine has rejected the idea of
negotiations
they want to negotiate but they have
written Russia here forever they want to
negotiate with us and keep bombing the
infrastructure they wanted to ceasefire
but they're not talking about the
withdrawal of their forces from the
entire territory of Ukraine because they
need an operational pause not peace
a city that resisted the occupation when
it began almost nine months ago until
that resistance proved futile that was
so recently proclaimed Russian Forever
by Vladimir Putin has proven itself in
scenes of euphoria that won't end
anytime soon to be Ukrainian to its core
the question now is whether Ukrainian
troops can replicate this Victory
elsewhere in the country fighting in the
East is particularly intense but with
the return of the regional Capital to
Ukrainian hands and the morale boost
that comes with it they believe they can
win this war
Assad Bank Al Jazeera crivery